hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play dread halls as
you can see I'm already blinded and
right in the game because I am finally
playing another
oculus rift horror game I've been
incredibly busy this entire week I've
been here but thankfully I finally
managed to get some time to myself to
really get into it and um this piranhas
in particular excuse me I'm spitting all
over the place but this one in
particular looks absolutely incredible
and I'm really excited to be able to
play it I'm kind of kind of crooked here
I think or am i I'm a little crooked ok
anyway let's get into it I'm actually
gonna need I got in just to test the
mechanics of it and it's it is it is
freaky man
it is freaky but I do need a mouse in
order to navigate a bit here I wish I
had a gamepad but unfortunately I do not
so anyway
oh this is so weird oh my god look at
the frickin wall hello
someone in the darkness okay this is
really weird using the uh now send up
both the oculus rift to turn my edit
this is so weird
oh my god if you've never had tried to
not get stripped before you really need
to it is I hear that is that actually
something when I tried these games I've
never oh [ __ ] that what was that what up
what the ass what the hell was that oh
shut up okay I don't know what's real
and I don't know it's fake to it so
let's just go down use the oil in your
inventory to fuel your light what how do
I get my inventory I can't exactly see
my keyboard right now so oh my god I
hear noises I hear noises guys hold
right mouse button to open in boo doors
look at oil bottle Andrew these gold
coins oh oh that is much better still
kind of bad serious you guys get a nook
what is down there wait I see something
down there what is that what is that we
still don't know what is that it's gonna
go oh my god I don't want to know I
don't want to know I don't know what
that I don't want to know what that is
oh I got one extra chicken what is this
but it is like let you oh oh oh oh no oh
no no no no no I will not choose between
that in the girl oh no oh no no
absolutely not I think whatever that was
just walked by where to go
we're never good to go what happened
where'd you go Oh what the hell is that
shot thought that's behind me Holy
Mother of oh ok hi what is this
I'm sorry what is this oil
what is that Matt dad my man I don't
know what the hell is going on guys but
this is absolutely incredible oh my god
it's so weird
shut your face I see something there is
that gold coins can I collect that okay
I did oh here you are you actually a
thing oh please don't be a thing oh my
god I don't want to move forward guys I
really don't you may think that I'm a
big baby but just freaking try this God
dang it okay I'm gonna assume that most
of those noises are not actually
anything and I'm actually okay to move
fairly decently I just need to I
probably need to oh don't do that oh
don't do that okay
what is it what is that what is it oh my
god oh no it's not
let us not and say we never did how
about you go to hell and you die
whatever the hell you are oh my god what
was that thing okay that's the thing
that was that's the thing that was
stalking me in the halls oh that doesn't
work try to just lead over
was that oh my god the 3d sound in this
game is amazing I swear I hear
everything behind me it's very well done
get some good quality headphones when
you play this I mean even if you were
playing this without the oculus rift
this would be terrifying but seriously
the oculus rift makes it seem like I'm
not in my hotel room anymore I kind of
have forgotten that I'm in my hotel room
safe and sound it's surrounded by
darkness if there's a frickin shadow
behind me I swear to god you guys would
tell me right
I don't know like this I do not like
this oh my god I do not like this okay I
don't even know what I'm looking for how
did I get in here move what's up with
that little girl oh okay um kind of a
narrow path down here it's uh okay let's
not okay I changed my mind on that one
okay never mind I'll go back that way
what do you want from a globe Oh God no
no no no good good doo doo doo oh my god
that is a girl she appears in the past
my mom I'm almost out of oil oh [ __ ] you
what is it
she taking the Dargis you'll be oil okay
since the statue what what what no no
you're not gonna be a little edgy be one
[ __ ] you one [ __ ] three
oh [ __ ] you oh do not be like that you
bastard oh you bastard oh you
[ __ ] give me oh can you just
chillaxing their breath oh my god oh my
god with the Arcas rift oh look at me oh
I [ __ ] looked at me oh my god
Oh kisses oh my god I can't take this ah
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you
alright I'm a man I'm a man [ __ ] you
[ __ ] you statue we surely did I am I am
I mistaken in that it looked at me what
is that what's going on I heard
something okay [ __ ] you everything about
you
I left that map there but I don't even
care I'm keeping my eye on you you [ __ ]
oh wait no no no no no no no no no no my
gym oh well I can't do that well I am
actually crying I
I couldn't do it I really couldn't do it
oh my god
this is I've only played like one other
oculus rift war game and seriously it
was not like that
oh you're sweating so much oh man you
guys gotta give that a try if you can I
don't know how long I've been recording
for I don't even know I can't see cuz
everything's full screen right now oh my
god alright I'll go back in do it for
you guys oh my god I'm not joking in the
least about this guy's
I'm not even clean clothes - kidding
this is absolutely terrifying
I've never where's my WASD I don't even
know I'm there we go okay
I seriously I couldn't handle it it was
gargoyle and it was screaming at me and
killing me I don't know okay you all
shut up I'm not even I'm not even
halfway into the game yet
let's go so there's like three different
things there's that girl that just pops
up and making my oil here
let's just go I've stood around a long
time wasting oil so oh man I don't want
to play oh shut the [ __ ] up what was
that what is that what is that oh oh
yeah oh yeah oh don't don't don't don't
don't no doubt out what a [ __ ] who are
you oh yeah boy dude what is happening
what is that oh my god I don't want to
look at it I don't wanna look at it it's
not not screaming at me
it's not screaming at me I'm closing the
door and oh my god it's just a series of
doors it's just a series of [ __ ]
doors with my map the hell am i oh
but I'm a professional this is what I
chose
okay nothing down there I don't even
know what I'm looking for I really do
not guys I do not know I don't I'm gonna
shut up [ __ ] you it's unreal it's hard
to describe I'm trying to do halfway
decent commentary on this and I I can't
find the words to describe it um it's
just it puts the objects shot dumb it
puts the objects like literally so that
it feels like they're inches from your
face I am not joking it is even though
this is the developer version with like
lower resolution it doesn't matter it is
when you think a monster is 2 inches
from your face you freak out it's just
it happens I can't help it it [ __ ]
happens I'm not exaggerating I don't
even give a [ __ ] if you think that I'm
like faking I don't give a [ __ ] I really
don't you play this for yourself
and tell me it's not scary what is that
the more oil what is that what is that
and okay what is that
so the way out no it's just a freaking
torch can I take that with me god damn
it
I'm guessing that this is all
procedurally generated
oh [ __ ] you where we going
well this is a big dead end was there
something else here I don't know oh god
damn it
uh-huh nope I didn't trigger it I didn't
trigger I did not just backing out of
here [ __ ] you [ __ ] you yeah that's right
where am I going
okay I need to go right oh shut up
goddamn what is that oh that's a door I
can barely see things that are inches
from my face
Edie what is that I've been saying what
is that way too much I haven't been
looking with my head i'd-- if it played
with the mouse I don't want to look with
my head that makes it more real
coin okay yes oh [ __ ] me oh [ __ ] me so
hard did I trigger it I don't even know
if I do trigger it I don't know it's
keeping my eye on it getting around a
corner okay two bottles of oil that's do
oh [ __ ] you oh they're even away okay
there is a way out of here okay
just down that way but oh you turned
around you son of a [ __ ] don't think I
don't know so good oh stop it that's odd
what I know oh my god what'd I do
oh my god it was actually behind me oh
yeah oh [ __ ] you
oh [ __ ] you oh [ __ ] you I don't even
know I don't even know it sounded like
he was dead behind me oh my god did it
go away or is it this is oh wow oh wow
the statue right there what is that what
is that I don't know I don't know I
don't I don't
[ __ ] you guy huh [ __ ] yo god damn it oh
god you don't you don't know it's it's
just never mind I'm tired of explaining
myself just [ __ ] it what is it what is
it what is that what is it I [ __ ] it I'm
throwing another way where's another way
there's another way just down here it's
another way just down this way if I go
down this hole should be something else
okay
unless this just loops back to where I
started I don't really care at this
point okay all right I'm gonna go under
there's something that no noise is not
something everything every noise I hear
is actually something in the game that
is trying to kill me that's one of the
nice Oh poop Oh God
oh my god okay I don't know what that
wasn't pride just a [ __ ] jump here
was it something no it was nothing
what the Oh excellent ly hit I got two
gold coins is that even worth it day 17
we keep going deeper it's hard to find
food now I don't know I don't care about
the notes I don't care about the story I
don't care
oh shut up that's actually something
isn't it listen that everything is
actually something okay I heard that
noise okay good that another note
yes more oil boy okay I don't even care
I don't even freaking care about the
coins I don't I really just I want to be
done with this I really want to be done
with this because I am very tired very
tired of playing this game I'm very
tired oh shut up shut up shut up shut up
shut the [ __ ] up
oh I want to go home please
is that like light to an exit or
something kind of take a weapon
okay I've got to be getting close to
something I've got to be getting close
to something then going through this
freaking place it's just an endless
series of halls filled with evils and
what's worse is that I haven't seen
anything for a while I think that you
think that make me feel better but I
really do not don't want it I don't want
anything this is a freaking dead end
damn it I'm just going in circles not
going anywhere
oh is that something is that something
is that something is that something is
there something all that something isn't
that's something open open oh no oh okay
oh god oh god it's Bobby I can hear it
what'd you do oh just go away just go
away going in it's the exit oh boy oh go
away you bastard just close it close it
close approval oh god oh god oh oh [ __ ]
oh my god where do I go it's just so
fricking I can't even see front runner
shut the [ __ ] up
my [ __ ] mind
I swear to God three notes I don't care
it's [ __ ] cage she's still there
she's still there she's not there
anymore she [ __ ] two peers and
disappeared
I've been cursing way too much in this
playthrough I'm sorry Jess how am I
looking on my head on the microphone
I'm just going into dead ends
non-stop Oh Oh goodbye
Oh goodbye stove I'm an that's good
maybe use guarding something I don't
know where we going now oh my god this
place is a [ __ ] maze
I'm gonna try to reach the end try
they haven't been bothering me that much
I guess that's a good thing
what is that being tired of asking that
question she's just no better I'm never
gonna find out
damnit I've been down here okay I didn't
go in this big from on the left here I
down there
everybody's shut up okay there's a
statue there it shouldn't be a problem
if I just I don't I don't even know if
that thing can kill me
I think it's just there to startle me
pretty sure yeah hi god damn it you're
really cool
oh don't look at me buddy don't look at
me okay so it actually can hurt me I
didn't know it could actually hurt me
there's nothing here there was no point
to come in here [ __ ] you don't look at
me don't look at me don't [ __ ] look
at all right I'm gonna go left out of
this hall and then I'm gonna make it
right but I'm gonna wait until this guy
gets around a corner come on where's the
[ __ ] edge okay okay I hope I really
hope Oh make it right it's down here
another freakin door great door that
leads to nothing absolutely nothing god
oh man these randomly generated games
are the worst for horror no best for
horror but I mean you know what I mean
when I say worst I just mean I don't
like them that because they scare me Oh
God
oh god I'm tired I can't run I'm gonna
die
oh just shut up I'm done where did I go
okay where's this room get out this way
and go right and then there's not much
left to this place I've been everywhere
I don't know what I'm looking for
I really don't oh shut up no no no no no
how is that fair how is that fair oh god
damn it you know what just screw it
screw it I'm going around the other way
just [ __ ] you God can't you run for more
than 10 steps at a time okay all right
shut up okay that guy's not that big of
a problem you just run away from it he
startled me just because you can't
popped up out of nowhere that one's not
what I'm worried about
the one that I'm wearing of the gargoyle
and that guy I'm perfectly okay with the
only one that I don't get is a frickin
little girl forget little girls are
scary no matter what game they're in so
it doesn't matter I don't care I am done
I'm so done with this game I'm so done
with this game I want it done I want to
never play it again that's why I want to
get to the ending whatever it may be I
just want to get to it and then I will
be the hop this this there's only one
path go left it's down this way that's
all that's left there literally is
nothing left on my map don't
don't kill me now of all the times to
kill me okay I'm gonna take a little bet
here
right what is that what is that wait no
I see something Don do you guys see that
or am I just [ __ ] with myself okay I
saw something down here a light the end
of a hallway
it's another door again damn it maybe it
leads somewhere what is that
was that is that a good light [ __ ]
hell there's nothing here
this is friggin dead bodies in a light
that's the thing I saw I saw
I must say it must I must have just saw
through the wall or something and gotta
be careful
that little girl can pop up anywhere
okay there's there's still not many
places to go I'm getting close to the
end I think I hope I pray
okay what is that is that a good glow is
that a good glow you've led me astray
before oh my god get me out here oh my
god come on come on oh oh oh light oh my
god
light oh my god oh my god Oh design and
development by Sergio Hidalgo oh my god
Oh oh my god I made it oh I made it made
it oh my god I don't oh my god oh I made
it I made it I mean I'm done I'm done I
can get out you know
thank you for scaring me oh my god oh oh
man oh that was an ordeal that was hard
it was really hard I wanted to stop
really really badly like really badly
sorry that's probably disorienting for
you guys we'll just set this down I
think I really really really really
wanted to stop you guys couldn't see but
I was I'm a baby
coming to that game I'm it's like the
the point of horror in games is to feel
immersion and that's when you feel the
most scared um but it's there's
immersion and then there's a monster two
inches from your face
when you're in here it's totally
different there is no comparison to
anything that I've ever played before
and I'm going to call this one of the
scariest games I've ever played simply
by the fact that it had really good
mechanics procedurally generated and I
didn't understand how that little girl
worked because sometimes I saw and then
I sometimes I saw her with her face just
freaking out and sometimes she just
stood there sometimes she chased me I
did not know the gargoyle was really
well done that look that look what's
amazing I never expected that especially
when I was staring at it an intra by
vase
that was one that was really solid um
you know some of these games have
hallways that aren't procedurally
generated this one is procedurally
generated the monster patrolling is
pretty typical of a horror game normally
if you get an indie horror game like
this you just have that monster
patrolling the halls and it's not that
scary but with everything else I mean
just turning around seeing a skeleton it
was amazing if you really really really
like horror and if you really really
really like to be scared I cannot
recommend this more I'm going to have
nightmares I'm honestly forgotten and I
sat in there like I think I said I
usually don't [ __ ] around like that
but um yeah I was not messing around
but I really don't care if you think
that any of that was fake because it was
not and I really really had to push
myself to get back in the game
so you were welcome everybody hope you
don't have to go through it yourself I
am dead serious this was terrifying so
anyway I got to the end though so I
never have to play it again thank you so
much
but I will be playing oculus rift or in
the future if you want to see me get
scared more than I ever have but that
was that was very solid that was a very
good game I was very well done I mean I
think the gold coins were just a red
herring he didn't even have a score at
the end so I don't think it mattered
I didn't read through the notes cuz I
was not in the mood to read him but that
was just that was absolutely phenomenal
I can't recommend it more that's all I
have to say I bladdered on enough I am a
fish I should be by the time you're
watching this I should be back in
Cincinnati Ohio so I should be back home
and I've got a lot of stuff in store for
you guys some really cool things that
I'm going to be working on in that I've
already worked on from this week-long
trip in Los Angeles um it's really been
worth it if you guys haven't been
following me on Twitter and Facebook you
you don't know what I've been doing and
I just been really cool stuff meeting
people in working with things I've done
sketch comedy I've done things that were
going to be animated I've done
funny some of the funniest videos I've
ever done I did a drunk thing and you're
really going to like it so sincerely
like I said you know before I do this
because you guys like it and you guys
support me so I I'm willing to put
myself through this the horror that is
this for you guys is entertainment
because I really like making videos that
you love so just keep it up man you know
I am here because of you I'm here
because you guys tell your friends about
me I'm here because you share my videos
around and I'm gonna be working on a lot
of things to get more engaged with the
community and I hope to do that in the
near future but I've been blabbering on
forever because it's compensation
mechanism I guess to talk to anyway I'm
done sincerely thank you guys so much
for watching that's all I got so thanks
again I'll see you in the next video bye
bye